مرحبًا ، أنا هل قمت بسرقة مسيرتي المهنية
كعارضة أزياء تجعلني لست رجلاً بشكل افتراضي ،
بيتي في أماكن متعددة حول
العالم في هذا اليوم وأصبحت العائلة في هذا العصر
عالماً جميلاً متعدد الاستخدامات
حيث أصبح العالم أكثر ارتباطًا و
كثير منا يتحرك باستمرار
بعيدًا عن مكان ولادتنا ، نبدأ في
إنشاء نفس النوع من تلك التي تعلمناها من أي وقت مضى.
قد تسمع أن شخصًا
ما قد قُتل على يد الأشرار
وسيشعر الجميع بالخوف وسيبدأون في
تعبئة أغراضنا استعدادًا
للفرار إلى المكان التالي الأكثر أمانًا والذي كان
الحياة حتى حصلنا أخيرًا
على التأشيرة وانتقلنا إلى أستراليا
في مكان ما  مثل أستراليا ، كما تعلم ، يمكنك
أن تصبح أي شيء تريد
أن تصبح طالما أنك فقط تضع
عقلك على ما وأنت تعمل بجد فقط
يمكنك تحقيق أي شيء على الرغم من أن حياتي
بدأت مع أشكال مختلفة من الإزاحة
أحاطت بي عائلتي ودعمتني على
مدار سنوات
[الموسيقى]
اليوم ، لقد عرّفني مسيرتي المهنية في صناعة الأزياء
على عائلة إبداعية ضخمة ،
كل صورة وكل
مجموعة نتيجة للعلاقات المختلفة من
خلال أخبار الموضة
أصبحت بيتي الثاني هنا  أنني
وجدت نوعًا آخر من الأساس
يقبلني أصدقائي دون قيد أو شرط
بالطريقة التي يتعامل بها أحد أفراد الأسرة مع عملي
التحريري ، أردت أن أكتشف كيف
تفرع معناه وكيف
أصبح يمثل شيئًا أعمق
بكثير من روابط الدم التي أرغب في إظهارها للعالم
من خلال صوتي وخبراتي أنه
على الرغم من كل الاختلافات
والخلافات بيننا يمكننا أن نكون عائلة لبعضنا
البعض
[موسيقى]